conspiracy theorist and infowars host
alex jones has made it clear that he is
done with donald trump and he is indeed
going to be backing ron desantis if the
florida governor decides to run for
president in 2024 now as much as i'd
like to say who cares what alex jones
says who cares what he thinks the guy's
a nut case after all we can dismiss him
this actually is pretty significant
because if he's able to turn his loyal
viewers and listeners from being trump
supporters and make them run to santa's
voters well that could make the
difference in a potential contested
primary between the two candidates let's
take a look at what jones had to say on
his infowars program earlier this week
pigheadedly support him
a few years ago even though i disagree
with his warp speed
because i thought
that we had to keep him in office
because of the nightmare scenario if
hillary or biden got in
back before they were officially running
but that said i am supporting desantis
the santa is just gone from being
awesome to being
unbelievably good
and i don't just watch a man's actions
as christ said judge a tree by his
fruits
i can also look in his eyes on hd video
and i see the real sincerity this is
what trump should be like and i've been
hammering this point
and he's doing it now
and
we have someone that is better than
trump
way better than trump now at least in
this clip alex jones didn't articulate
why exactly he likes ron desantis more
than donald trump i'd imagine it has
somewhat to do with the right-wing
culture war issues that desantis has
been championing over the past couple of
years everything from making these
decrees against socialism to passing his
don't say gay bill to the anti-trans
rhetoric to saying that oh well the left
supposedly wants to defund the police
but here in florida we're funding the
police but the real sticking point for
jones seems to be the vaccine issue the
fact that donald trump is not an
outright anti-vaxxer at least as it
pertains to the coveted vaccine and
that's really just because he wants to
take credit for it credit for operation
warp speed and jones predicted of course
that the vaccine would do all these
terrible things but then you look back
and after billions of doses have been
administered everyone's doing just fine
so maybe he's moved the goal posts on
that just as a reminder here's a clip
from back in december when alex jones
did a special emergency christmas day
edition of his show to declare that
trump is ignorant or evil because of his
stance on the coveted vaccines this is
an emergency christmas day warning to
president trump
you were either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy
that you helped ram through with
operation warp speed
or you're one of the most evil men who
has ever lived
to push
this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when
they simply try to save their lives and
the lives of others we're about to lay
out the basic incontrovertible facts
that what you told candace owens just a
few days ago is nothing but a raft of
dirty lies now maybe it's illogical for
me to try to get inside the head of alex
jones and understand why exactly he's
making this pivot and who knows if jones
even believes half the things that he
says right so maybe he doesn't even care
one way or another between trump or
desantis but it is a little bit strange
right because when jones decided to hit
his wagon to trump back in 2016 it at
least made a little bit of sense because
trump at the time was painting himself
as an anti-establishment figure he was
going to be an outsider who would shake
things up in washington and drain the
swamp as he liked to say ron desantis
though on the other hand he's pretty
much just a standard republican like he
he knows how to play the culture war
games better than the average republican
politician and he's clearly learned a
thing or two from trump about how to
deal with the media and how to present
himself but at the end of the day he's a
pretty establishment guy which jones has
really never been into so it's all very
weird and i do think it actually could
be relevant to a potential matchup
between the two figures so we'll have to
see if maybe ron desantis ever decides
to appear on alex jones's show like
donald trump did back in 2016 maybe he
won't because desantis may realize that
jones is a little bit too toxic right
now to associate with but that's the
latest alex jones done with donald trump
and moving over to ron desantis
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below